bonsoir londres en état de choc après la
catastrophe du métro qui a fait je vous
le rappelle 32 morts et une centaine de
blessés vingt-quatre heures après et les
anglais s'interroge et relance le débat
sur la réussite et de leur métro
jacques chirac que le financement des
partis je souhaite qu'un projet puisse
aboutir très rapidement c'est à dire
avant les élections présidentielles la
privatisation du crédit agricole en
discussion devant la semaine nationale
mais la réalisation du projet pourrait
être perturbé par la faiblesse du marché
financier inquiétudes et interrogations
en espagne autour du rapt de mélodies
les ravisseurs baisse à nouveau le
montant de la rançon
la presse et la police fouille le passé
du père de la fillette les tricolores à
la recherche de leurs géniteurs du le
doute s'installe au sein de l'équipe de
france après une nouvelle défaite face à
la paire d as une journée supplémentaire
de détention pour marcel carton
marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann jean
louis normandin d'antenne 2 et roger
auque les otages français au liban n'ont
toujours pas été libérés
panique dans le métro londonien tout a
commencé hier soir par un incendie de
papiers gras sous un escalier mécanique
très vite ce qui n'aurait pu être qu'un
banal fait divers a tourné à la
catastrophe
il faut dire que le métro de londres est
l'un des plus vétustes du monde
sa construction remonte à 1863 et les
opérations de rénovation n'y sont pas
chose courante
aujourd'hui tout le monde mais dit sur
le rapport d'un sociologue britannique
il y a trois mois il écrivait notamment
en cas d'urgence les communications sont
chaotiques les mesures d'organisation
complètement inefficace hugo reading
c'est son nom n'avait pas été entendu à
londres reportage de philippe harrouard
c'est dans cette salle des tickets
qu'ont péri la plupart des victimes en
pleine obscurité étouffant sous une
épaisse fumée dans une chaleur
insupportable qui a fait se désintégrer
les plafonds les malheureux voyageurs
ont été pris dans une souricière
le feu avait débuté vers 20h45 au sommet
d'un escalier mécanique en bois seule
sortie possible
le sinistre aurait pris naissance sur
l'escalier mécanique et non en dessous
comme on l'a cru au départ en quelques
minutes cela a été la panique parmi les
voyageurs encore nombreux dans cette
station la plus fréquentée de long le
seul salut comme l'expliquent ce rescapé
c'était de redescendre sur le quai et de
prendre le métro qui a continué à
fonctionner les secours ont été rapides
mais les sauveteurs ont été gênés
la fumée la chaleur et les débris il n'y
avait pas de détecteur de fumée il n'y
avait pas de sorties de secours alors
beaucoup de voix s'élèvent ici pour dire
que décidément la sécurité maximum n'est
pas assurée dans le métro de londres
voici un de ces vieux escalier de bois
comme celui de keynes france plus de 200
sont encore en service
leur remplacement se fait au compte
gouttes c'est une question d'argent
d'autres accidents graves ont eu lieu
dans le passé comme oxford circus
il y a trois ans la station a
partiellement brûlé sans faire de
victimes et amour gates en 1975 où la
collision entre deux rames avaient été
43 main madame thatcher qui a visité la
station de king's cross aujourd'hui
s'est dit horrifié et a promis une
enquête complète sur la tragédie ici à
londres
on réclame surtout de véritables mesures
pour assurer la sécurité des 2 millions
de passagers qui prennent chaque jour le
métro
coïncidence hier soir à paris au moment
même où la panique faisait rage dans le
métro londonien
les responsables de la ratp organisait
une simulation d'accident à la station
reuilly diderot
tout le monde était mobilisé le
personnel de la ratp les pompiers le
samu
but de l'opération tester le système de
sécurité
un exercice d' alerte en temps réel qui
devrait rassurer les 5 millions de
parisiens qui utilisent le métro
quotidiennement
patrice volet alerte dans le métro
parisien
un court-circuit une rame en feu dix
minutes après l'accident les premiers
secours arrivent sur les lieux
exercice grandeur nature pour les
pompiers premiers soins et évacuation
des blessés plusieurs fois par an des
interventions fictive comme celle ci
objectif coordonner les secours tester
leur efficacité selon la ratp
mention bien pour l'exercice de cette
nuit mais après l'accident de londres
les escalators en bois du métro parisien
deviennent suspects une cinquantaine
d'exemplaires ont échappé à la
modernisation des lignes des équipements
anciens sous haute surveillance
la plupart de ces escaliers mécaniques
sont munis de systèmes de détection est
sans doute ce qui veut dire que si un
incendie se déclarait dans un escalier
mécanique
l'agent de d'exploitation delà de la
gare ou de la station se serait
immédiatement prévenu
issue de secours matériaux anti fumée et
surtout extincteur accessibles au public
le métro parisien a toujours pensé à la
sécurité de ses voyageurs un seul
incendie grave depuis le début du siècle
83 morts c'était en 1903 jacques chirac
en voyage à la réunion le premier
ministre a commencé très visite marathon
par un discours très dur vous allez
l'entendre l'égard de ses prédécesseurs
les gouvernements de gauche at il dit se
sont intéressés à l'outre-mer pour des
raisons politiques
en oubliant les actions économiques et
sociales récit de notre envoyé spécial
jean louis le scène en atterrissant ce
matin à saint denis jacques chirac
savait que sa journée serait chargé
trois dossiers prioritaires ici et
notamment la formation des jeunes un
réunionnais sur deux a moins de 20 ans
un succès doit aller chercher du travail
en métropole
mais le premier ministre a fait le
voyage avant tout pour dresser le bilan
global de l'action de son gouvernement
depuis 18 mois et vérifier l'application
de la loi programme pour l'outre-mer
voté en décembre 86 et jacques chirac ne
s'en prendre une fois encore à
l'héritage socialiste
en vérité le gouvernement précédent ne
s'était pas intéressé à l'outre-mer
si ce n'est sur un autre plan celui de
la politique politicienne
l'absence totale de préoccupation et
d'action économique ou social ceux qui
se sont rendus coupables d'un tel
désintéressement qu'il soit socialiste
où qu'ils soient communistes car ils
étaient ensemble au gouvernement au
début de la précédente législature n'ont
aucune leçon à donner à quiconque dans
le département natal de raymond barre
monsieur chirac ne pouvait pas ne pas
exhorté ses supporters à l'union de la
majorité
aucune voix ne doit manquer at il dit à
celui qui la représentera au dernier
stade de la compétition
message transmis quelques minutes plus
tard le premier ministre est également
revenu sur le financement des partis
politiques et sur l'invitation qu'il a
lancé hier aux différents leaders pour
la première fois jacques chirac
s'explique devant une caméra de
télévision écouter le le je le répète
suivant s'agissant de moraliser même si
l'efficacité n'est pas forcément total
notre vie publique
j'ai donc invité les chefs et
responsables de toutes les formations
politiques représentées à l'assemblée
nationale la semaine prochaine date être
fixé très prochainement pour voir avec
ces responsables
ce que nous devons et pouvons faire et
je souhaite qu'ils en sortent très
rapidement c'est à dire naturellement
avant la présidentielle
un texte qui nous permettent je dirais
de franchir une étape importante dans la
voie de de plus de transparence de plus
de moralisation dans notre vie politique
qui n'est pas d'ailleurs plus immoral
que celle de quelque pays que ce choix
le dollar à 5 francs 70 baisse de 1 72%
à la bourse de paris
apparemment paris encaisse mal le
mauvais chiffres du commerce extérieur
et attend comme tout les places
boursières et monétaires un accord entre
la maison blanche et le congrès pour se
refaire une petite santé
à washington on murmure que l'accord
pourrait être annoncé ce soir mais pour
l'instant rien d'officiel
en attendant à l'assemblée nationale le
crédit agricole est au coeur du débat
depuis cet après midi monsieur balladur
défend son projet de privatisation ou
plutôt de mutualisation du crédit
agricole
le principe est simple les caisses
régionales 94 pour acheter la caisse
centrale parisienne
le prix de vente de la caisse centrale
ne sera connu qu'en janvier mais le
processus de rachat est déjà bien
engagée
maryse mano et roger mathurin sont en
mesure de nous dire que la première
qu'est ce qui va se jeter à l'eau entre
guillemets et celle du morbihan en
bretagne un véritable test dans la
sacoche de cet agent de change
un gros dossier le premier dossier de la
mutualisation du crédit agricole
son client la caisse du morbihan elle
traite pas son introduction à la bourse
de nantes
l'objectif récolter l'argent nécessaire
pour acheter sa part de la caisse
nationale pas ici d'une caisse régionale
en l'occurrence celle de morbihan c'est
la première fois effectivement si
l'opération se réalise que cette caisse
seraient cotées sur une bourse de
province
je pense qu'effectivement dans ce
dossier nous travaillons pour l'ensemble
du crédit agricole la caisse du morbihan
débroussailler le terrain pour les 93
autres caisses comme les autres elle a
besoin d'argent frais 50 millions de
francs pour acheter la caisse nationale
sans dégarnir ses fonds propres le moyen
choisi l'émission de certificats
d'investissement mais le jour j
mardi 10 novembre la jambe change
apprend que la cob la commission des
opérations de bourse a retardé
l'opération
ce jour là la bourse a perdu 6% il est
exclu de faire une opération en bourse
dans cette période troublée dans tous
les cas il faut il attendre de meilleurs
jours et vous voyez donc l'introduction
et crédit agricole possible à quelle
date
je souhaite très rapidement si ça peut
être en décembre de très sérieux ça veut
dire que le marché à nouveau et
équilibrée à retrouver une vie normale
le crédit agricole aura bien besoin
d'une bourse plus calme s'il veut
poursuivre sa privatisation
car si le morbihan n'a besoin que d'une
petite somme l'ensemble des caisses
s'apprête à ponctionner 5 milliards de
francs
compte tenu de la pousse des
privatisations et les troubles
persistants de la bourse
rien ne dit que le crédit agricole va
dans le bon sens
à part cela le mauvais chiffres du
commerce extérieur - 4 9 milliards de
francs suscite aujourd'hui encore
commentaires et interrogations
certains parlent de descente aux enfers
c'est peut-être un peu fort d'autres
évoquent qu'un accident de parcours un
accident qui serait dû aux importations
massives d'automobiles bref la baisse de
la tva aurait largement profité aux
modèles étrangers
alain dubé ce qui au cours des neuf
premiers mois de l'année le secteur
automobile a été largement excédentaire
c'est le mois d'octobre qui est montré
du doigt par le gouvernement des effets
de la baisse de la tva se sont fait
sentir les français ont acheté 24 % de
véhicules de plus qu en octobre 86 les
deux tiers de ses achats supplémentaires
se sont portés vers des modèles français
le troisième tir bien sûr ce sont les
achats supplémentaires de voitures
étrangères
il aurait suffi à rendre déficitaires de
500 millions de francs notre marché
automobile au mois d'octobre
les résultats des constructeurs
étrangers sont très inégaux selon les
marques ford le premier importateur de
voitures en france a vu son chiffre de
vente divisé par deux entre octobre 86
et octobre 87 fiat par contre a fait
mieux que les français avec 37% de
voitures en plus si notre industrie
automobile a su prendre la plus large
part de l'augmentation des ventes en
france au cours du mois d'octobre
elle a peut être ralenti ses efforts
vers l'étranger seuls les chiffres devra
le préciser d'ici quelques semaines
expliquant ainsi ce premier déficit de
l'année mais les résultats automobile ne
doivent pas être jugé sur un seul mois
importations exportations dépend des
dates de livraison des mis sur le marché
ou bien de la tente des nouveaux modèles
par les acheteurs pendant une période
plus significative les neuf premiers
mois de l'année par exemple la france a
exporté pour 79 milliards de francs deux
véhicules une progression de 8,3 pour
cent par rapport à l'an dernier
pendant ces mêmes neuf mois nous
importions pour 62 milliard et demi de
francs de véhicules étrangers
ces chiffres portant sur trois
trimestres représente une tendance
générale beaucoup plus favorable aux
marques françaises
85 % des patrons veulent renforcer le
rôle de l'entreprise dans la formation
des jeunes c'est le résultat d'un
sondage publié aujourd'hui dans le
nouvel économiste chiffres au combien
d'actualité d'autant que rené monory le
ministre et françois périgot le patron
des patrons viennent de créer un groupe
de travail destiné précisément au
développement des stages en entreprise
les postulants devront préparer le bac
professionnel
un bac créé il ya deux ans un exemple
pour mieux comprendre celui d'un lycéen
dans la région parisienne
reportage de leurs aînés clusaz
troisième stage professionnel pour
laurent qui passeront jma un bac de
carrosserie automobile toujours assisté
de son tuteur l'homme en blouse blanche
il va occuper plusieurs postes de
travail la note de stage compte pour le
bas objectif est en prise avec la
réalité
j'étais déjà très impressionné ça change
ça change beaucoup par rapport à notre
vie scolaire habituel c'est important ce
qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de faire ce
genre de travaux au lycée et c'est autre
chose on voit vraiment l'industrie d'une
autre façon nous entretenons des
relations permanentes avec les lycées
d'enseignement professionnel parce que
nous sommes conscients qu'aujourd'hui la
formation est un critère essentiel de
progrès pour l'entreprise durant son
stage laurent devra comprendre les
étapes de la fabrication en série d'un
véhicule pour le bac professionnel
un quart de la formation se déroule en
entreprise pour le reste aux lycées
l'enseignement théorique concerne tous
les aspects de la future branche
d'activité auront un potentiel de
connaissances théoriques qui leur
permettra de s'adapter plus rapidement
aux évolutions technologiques et
techniques et je pense qu'ils ont une
formation qui leur permet de pouvoir
envisager une carrière professionnelle
et de devenir cadre assez rapidement
dans les entreprises cette faculté
d'adaptation est un atout face aux
titulaires de ces ape ou de bep qui ont
souvent du mal à trouver du travail
développer le bac professionnel tout le
monde le désire mais les entrepreneurs
peuvent ils tous proposer des stages
positif pour l'élève problèmes des
entreprises c'est si vous voulez d'avoir
le matériel nécessaire pour qui
correspond à l'exigence de la formation
d'une part et deuxièmement d'avoir le
temps à consacrer à l'élève dans la
seule académie de versailles 300 société
collabore déjà avec les lycées mais en
89 deux fois plus de jeunes prépareront
le bac professionnel
reste à trouver les entreprises pour les
accueillir en suisse une évasion qui
fait grand bruit
trois semaines après avoir été condamné
à 20 ans de réclusion criminelle pour
trafic de drogue
charles altiéri s'est évadé hier du
pénitencier de borouz dans le canton de
vaud une évasion qui est d'autant plus
retentissante que charles altiéri était
impliqué dans l'assassinât du juge
michel commentaires d'hervé brusini
pour s'évader d'une prison suisse
apparemment il suffit d'écarter les
barreaux de sa cellule
c'est le précepte appliquée par charles
altiéri et ses complices un peu de
matériel subtilisé ou divers ateliers de
l'établissement câble électrique d'un
jardinier combinaison de travail et les
rouleaux de barbelés déployés sur 8
mètres de large ne sont plus que pk 10 6
truands ont ainsi fait la belle parmi
eux quelques gros poissons tout
particulièrement
charles altiéri trafiquants de drogue
condamné à 20 ans de réclusion après la
découverte d'un laboratoire de
fabrication d'héroïne près de fribourg
altiéri impliqué dans l'assassinât du
juge michel il avait avoué qu'il était
le pilote de la moto nous le tueur avait
frappé et puis altiris s'était rétracté
il devait être pourtant jugé en france
sur cette affaire altiéri et ses
acolytes se serait dirigé vers le jura
français
un important dispositif policier a été
mis en place au pénitencier de bochuz
on répare les dégâts en se jurant bien
que désormais les barreaux seront reliés
à des systèmes d'alarmé électronique
une façon d'améliorer les statistiques
depuis deux ans en suisse plus de 1000
détenus ont pris la clé des champs
anouar el sadate en israël c'était il y
a dix ans déjà
l'anniversaire a été saluée modestement
certains diront même avec une relative
indifférence une chose est certaine les
commémorations d'aujourd'hui sont sans
aucune commune mesure avec l'événement
qui s'était déroulé le 19 novembre 1977
de part et d'autre les hommes ont changé
vous le savez le traité a tenu bon mais
la paix n'est pas revenu pour autant
dans cette région du monde
jean-marc il use 19 novembre 77 le
courage celui du président égyptien
anouar el sadate pour tirer un trait sur
trois guerres sanglantes avec israël il
n'hésite pas à se rendre à jérusalem est
aux côtés de son ennemi d'hier le
premier ministre israélien menahem begin
sadate s'adressera directement ou par le
monde israël geste historique qui en
mars 79 à cames david aux états unis d
ce sera sur un traité de paix en bonne
et due forme entre l'egypte et israël
geste de défi adn millénaire moins de
deux ans plus tard le président sadate
le paiera de sa vie et tombera sous les
balles d'un fanatique
aujourd'hui les israéliens ont quitté le
sinaï restituer à l'egypte
aujourd'hui le drapeau égyptien flotte
dans ce faubourg de tel aviv sur une
très officielle ambassades d'égypte
dix ans déjà la paix a tenu bon mais les
échanges économiques et humains entre
les deux ennemis d'hier reste bien
modeste un pan entier des accords de
camp david est restée lettre morte
celui qui concerne le sort d un million
deux cent mille palestiniens des
territoires occupés par israël depuis 67
le liban aura douloureusement hérité des
problèmes non résolus et aux confins de
l'arabie la guerre iran irak fait naître
de nouvelles peurs celle qui la semaine
dernière au sommet arabe d'amman auront
convaincu une majorité de pays arabes
obsédé par l'iran de pardonner à
l'egypte sont traités avec israël comme
si dix ans après les caprices de
l'histoire venait donner un nouveau
souffle aux rêves de paix du président
sadate voyons rapidement les autres
télégramme de l'étranger avec isabelle
stay sans suite nous reviendrons sur la
piètre prestation c'est le moins que
l'on puisse dire des footballeurs
français hier soir au parc des princes
face à la rdr
le raid iranien contre un hôpital au
nord-est de l'irak ce dernier bilan
s'élève à neuf morts et 64 blessés et
des tiers la riposte de l'iran au
bombardement de sa centrale nucléaire de
bouchehr a bien sûr irakiennes auraient
attaqué pour la troisième fois ce matin
les entreprises étrangères cible du
sentier lumineux à lima des guérilleros
s'attaque une usine du constructeur
automobile japonais nissan
l'assaut a été lancé de nuit à l'aide
d'explosifs quatre personnes ont été
tuées dans un affrontement avec la
police
trois tonnes de cocaïne les agents
fédéraux pulvérise le record des saisies
américaine valeur de la marchandise 62
millions de dollars sa provenance le
costa rica
elle était cachée dans un entrepôt de
miami sous près du siège de la lutte
anti drogue
automobile la plus chère du monde cette
bugatti royale de 1931 ce soir à londres
christie's l'a mis aux enchères
elle est estimée entre 9 et 12 millions
de dollars qui met 30 de l'office
chef-d'oeuvre d'ettore bugatti cnh a été
construit qu'à sept exemplaires
je rêve comme tout le monde en espagne
10 jours après le rapt l'ignoble
chantage se poursuit autour de la petite
mélodie
plusieurs centaines de personnes ont
manifesté aujourd'hui à malaga en criant
nous voulons toucher le coeur des
ravisseurs
apparemment ces derniers ne sont
sensibles qu'aux langage de l'argent aux
dernières nouvelles leur prétention sont
en baisse mais il réclame toujours 4
millions de dollars enquête gérard
beaufils et dominique verdeilhan entre
deux parcours de golf une partie de
tennis ou la réception du jour les
habitués de marbella commencent à
s'inquiéter de la mauvaise image de
marque que pourrait engendrer pour la
cité les suites de cette affaire
criminelle entre les ravisseurs et les
parents de mélodies
les négociations continuent pour la
libération de l'enfant mais aucun accord
pour l'instant est intervenue les
négociations achoppent encore sur le
montant de la rançon et les modalités de
paiement
de source policière on indique ce soir
en espagne que le passé de raymond à
cacher ans le père de la fillette n'a
rien à voir avec l'affairé en cours
accusé par la presse espagnole d'avoir
été mêlé par le passé à différents
trafics en grande bretagne le
milliardaire libanais serait en fait
refait ici une virginité dans les
affaires d'un premier mariage en
grande-bretagne raymond à cacher avait
déjà eu deux filles 2 fille
mystérieusement enlevés dans les années
nul ne sait si la rançon avait été payée
d'ailleurs les preneurs d'otages
les kidnappeurs n'ont jamais été
retrouvés il est apparu quelques
instants aujourd'hui devant les caméras
de télévision pour remercier les maires
andalouse qui lui envoient des chèques
afin de l'aider à réunir le montant de
la rançon demandée par les ravisseurs
cinq jeunes rapidement les résultats du
quartier du tiercé qui se disputaient
cette après midi à vincennes dans le
prix de l'orne qui était la cinquième
course le tiercé 19 3 7 apporte dans
l'ordre vous le voyez comme moi 16400 95
francs dans un ordre différent 3299
franc tout cela pour 5 francs
le kart et le quarté c'était le 19 3 7
et 4 dans l'ordre 235000 non fissile 235
1368 franc fait dans un ordre différent
19600 14 francs pour 5 francs c'est bien
payé football l'équipe de france sur la
touche elle a complètement raté sa
sortie du championnat d'europe des
nations et hier soir face à la rda
au delà du but encaissé à la toute
dernière seconde ça c'est pas de chance
c'est l'avenir du football français qui
se joue en ce moment j'en ma mère en dix
petites mais cauchemardesque secondes
le destin de l'équipe de france s'est
scellée hier soir un but malheureux mais
suffisant cependant pour qu'elle se
retrouve tout d'un coup le derrière par
terre sortie du parc sous les huées des
adorateurs de la veille le jardin est
devenu un enfer 10 secondes suffisante
pour faire ressurgir le fantôme de la
grande épopée des bleus
c'était il ya seulement trois ans la
page cette fois semble définitivement
tournée mais reste à savoir si tous en
sont bien conscients aussi créé quand
même des occasions bon on n'a pas eu la
chance de marquer et on se fait contrer
à tout donnant minutes pour 2 ce qui est
rageant
oui mais voilà le ciseau retourné de
cantona le tir sur le poteau de bruno
bellone en début de première mi temps
les actions offensives de poule 1 et 2
le roux pour faire la différence
ou bien encore la tête d' yvan leroux
rien rien a voulu rentrer et cela dure
depuis trop longtemps
cinq défaites dont 2 au parc en un an 4
matches nuls pour une victoire
la france s'en mêlent dans son football
et coursan grands espoirs après son
génie perdu la coupe est pleine et les
tribunes sont vides
voilà la vraie sanction
ça c'est incontestablement les
banquettes vides c'est une sanction
alors une question simple que ce poste
j'en suis sûr tous les téléspectateurs
avec moi parce qu on ira ou non à la
coupe du monde en 90 de malte en est où
le problème que va devoir résoudre à
michel car éliminer des jeux olympiques
et des championnats d'europe il ne reste
qu'une chance à la france pour se
racheter c'est cette fameuse coupe du
monde 1990 en italie
seulement voilà elle connaîtra ses
adversaires de qualification le 12
décembre prochain
et si l'on regarde le parcours que la
france a eu pendant championnat d'europe
des nations
terminer troisièmes ex-aequo juste
devant la norvège cela laisse craindre
le pire
et à partir de là tous les tirages au
sort sont difficiles le nouveau platini
fait qui suit pas il est il est certain
que le départ de tigana giresse ou
platini a laissé un grand vide mais plus
que les individualités c'est surtout un
groupe qui a disparu et qu'ils étaient
formés depuis une dizaine d'années en
fait aujourd'hui henri michel douarre
composer un groupe et une équipe soudée
il a jusque là essayer 37 joueurs depuis
la 1er 6 est beaucoup trop
il aura une chance peut-être de le
réussir c'est pendant la trêve
la tournée en israël qu'il va effectuer
avec cette équipe de france là peut-être
l'avenir se joue merci à part ça gardons
le moral histoire de nous remettre de
nos émotions je vous rappelle que nous
sommes le 19 novembre au 19 novembre ça
vous interpelle jean
je dirais que c'est le lendemain de la
défaite de l'équipe de france a toujours
sportif ma référence à moi c'est
l'arrivée des vins primeurs sur les
marchés joint on n'a pas les mêmes
références grande effervescence en
france et à l'étranger aujourd'hui vous
savez que les américains et les
britanniques sont très friands du
beaujolais nouveau
c'est aussi le cas des japonais ou la
précieuse cargaison vous allez l'avoir
est arrivé ce matin neuf cent mille
bouteilles et bien neuf cent mille
bouteilles au pays du soleil levant
il y avait tellement de bouteilles que
les douaniers japonais se sont contentés
de quelques petits coups de tampon pour
ne pas bloquer la précieuse marchandise
autre image impressionnante celle que
vous voyez de l'étiquetage quant à la
dégustation et bien la députée dans une
ambiance très française
et ça continue il y avait de l'ambiance
savez comment on dit beaujolais en
français en allemand en français oui en
japonais et on n'a pas vu avant on
n'avait pas mis sur les bons alors il
est bon ce beaujolais parce que je parle
de beaujolais nouveau il faut parler de
vin primeur il ya un 9/20 oui il ya une
scierie de primeurs il ya le beaujolais
il ya le côtes du rhône primeur il ya le
touraine primeur c'est le vin de chez
moi et du gaillac primeur et puis il ya
aussi des côtes du ventoux pied en blanc
il ya du mâcon primeur il ya du muscadet
primeur et puis il ya également du
gaillac blanc alors on a on a goûté un
petit peu tous très sagement parce que à
20,16 goûteux très légèrement il n'ya
plus le beaujolais le beaujolais bien
beaucoup mieux que l'an dernier où un
vin agréable
certains disent un peu à moi je trouve
un petit plus à 6 le hérisson un peu
raide dans ma main lush touraine primeur
le touraine primeur qu'il ait eu aussi
un petit peu acide mais il est pas
désagréable du tout en revanche est la
très bonne surprise c'est le côtes du
rhône
moi je ne réfléchis pas de salle
d'ailleurs à l'avoir trouvé très bien
très bon côtes du rhône six ans qu'il a
réussi une bonne année pierre laurent
blanc la très bonne surprise si en blanc
c'est muscadet c'est à vous avez tous
voté sous les projecteurs les noms les
agoutis dans d'excellentes conditions
avec ces conditions et alors là vraiment
côtes du rhône en rouge et un muscadet
en blanc ce sont deux très agréable
surprise cette année vous êtes docteur
mais vous êtes aussi oenologue c'est bon
ça pour l'estomac
donc c'est ça le jeu frites je ne ferai
pas la promotion du vin mais on aime les
gens qui s'occupent d'alcoologie les
médecins qui sont spécialisés alcoologie
n'interdisent pas que l'on boive à
condition de boire très peu et de très
bonne qualité
jamais un médecin ne vous dira ne buvait
pas de vince convient c'est ne vous
enivrer pas ne buvait pas trop mais les
personnes qui boivent un verre de vin
midi à l'heure devant le soir ne sont
pas pour autant des alcoolique invétéré
je ne vous le fais pas dire à consommer
avec modération
on ne peut plus de modération de la
qualité très peu le vert pour notre ami
météo c'est pour tout à l'heure nous on
va déguster les couronnes et en lui
laisser le soin de nous présenter les
prévisions avoue laurent
vous aurez la primeur donc de ses
prévisions météo avec une couche
nuageuse qui s'épaissit très
sérieusement fil des heures et au fil
des jours cette couche nuageuse et je
suis là cette couche nuageuse entre par
les îles britanniques mais comme notre
anticyclone est très costaud bien
résultat les nuages en arrivant chez
nous commence un peu à s'effriter c'est
pourquoi demain vers nous aurons un
temps quand même relativement agréable
sur l'ensemble de la france en dépit de
deux nuages menaçants sur les côtes du
littoral de la manche ainsi que sur la
bretagne la normandie le nord et la
picardie
la météo nationale prévoit également en
matinée seulement des nuages grisonnants
sur le pourtour méditerranéen avec un
vent mistral qui va souffler dans le
courant de l'après midi et qui va
dégager le ciel
les températures pour demain des
températures qui sont à la baisse en
général je vous laisse observer celles
qui sont proches de votre domicile
je vous rappelle qu'il y aura quelques
petites gelé quand même 1 degré à
mulhouse demain matin ainsi qu'à nancy
et à strasbourg
et il fera à 9 degrés août n'est ici
dans la mare d'une petit village qui
s'appelle verzy célèbre pour sa verdure
le vert de verzy parce que bien sûr
verdien vers demain et demain donc nous
serons le vendredi 20 novembre le soleil
se lèvera à 8h08 du couchera 17h04 et
bonne fête l'événement est ce que j'ai
dit le mot derrière tout ça j'ai donné
le programme prochain rendez-vous
d'information 23h30 avec aubry et de
l'air avant cela à 22h05 édition
spéciale présentée par notre collègue
bernard rapp un thème danger déchets
tout de suite à un extrait de ce
magazine
il y a là des milliers de fûts de
produits toxiques depuis 15 ans à
l'abandon nous sommes à néry dans l'oise
à une soixantaine de kilomètres de paris
de temps à autre un flux explose mais
pire encore on sait que dans cette
carrière de 67 à 72 des dizaines de
millions de litres de produits toxiques
ont été déversés directement dans le sol
sous les arbres
une dizaine de fûts bétonné celui ci
contient des fioles d'acide
chlorhydrique pur des autres fut n'ont
jamais été ouvert autour de la carrière
pas de protection n'importe quel enfant
peut venir y jouèrent à l'apprenti
chimiste est ici on trouve parfois du
cyanure les travaux d'assainissement ne
commenceront qu'après que la justice
aura désigne un responsable et depuis 15
ans le petit village de nerfs et vit à
côté d'une gigantesque poubelle
chimiques
voilà ce soir 22h05 sur antenne 2
antennes de notre société est à
l'honneur vous allez le voir henry perez
notre directeur général a reçu cet après
midi des mains de maurice ulrich qui est
directeur de cabinet de jacques chirac
la médaille de chevalier de la légion
d'honneur c'était sur l'un de nos
plateaux cet après midi
toutes nos félicitations excellente
soirée sur antenne 2 et à demain
n'oubliez pas le beaujolais nouveau ou
le vin primeur plutôt excellente soirée
à l'homme créé soir
m
à